what has happened and reject nation it
is Gregg al Bakir and is John Humphrey
over here we're gonna watch the trailer
today for future man Hulu TV series you
know there's a lot of TV shows on Hulu
that are supposedly good like the way
that one with James Franco yeah and this
show is directed by Seth Rogen and Evan
Goldberg they did not write it but they
direct I think is the first time they're
directing something that they did not
actually write oh man taking a plunge
that's a pretty big deal if the truth is
good enough I might actually have to get
a Hulu account now so it's the one
streaming service I don't have I have
everything else and then pretty soon
you're gonna have to get the Disney one
you have to get pop gotta get a
paramount Network every app every pretty
soon your family would be a page of the
day shoutout gonna be for Nathan Wilson
today
[Music]
whoa I'm not carrying disease from the
Year 2162 Oh everything that happens in
the biotic force is real whether the
game is a recruitment nutrient will sent
back in time to find the one person with
the skills to save us the first and only
person to appear in the game
that's the last starfighter exact same
plot as the movie what sort of movie is
this part of your arsenal weaponry oh my
god I pay my only Bitcoin for that huh
the key to stopping
we're in the future right there baby
absolutely not you cannot kill the baby
boom no they are helpless and they're
very soft perfect easy kill never
creates the cure and we can stop this
whole cycle before you begin we
cock-blocking you're supposed to up and
I brought with me from the future
[Music]
[Applause]
you tell me you've been back and forth
through time
just to avoid killing me
[Music]
this whole mission is insane what did
you think this was a game my birthday
money
[Music]
[ __ ] looks like you're gonna great a
more entertainment I want to check out
ah crap first world problem that looks
so entertaining it does look incredibly
like that Josh Hutcherson you know that
you know after coming off the Hunger
Games he's in the trailer for tragedy
girls I was a horror comedy ok and now
he's a star of this Hulu show which is a
sci-fi comedy dude
and genre comedy I'm happy that he's
still alive he looks like comedy might
be better suited for him I don't want to
pay attention yeah or comedy he busted
on the scene with I feel like he's got
you know the personality of the time I
didn't interviews and he's pretty funny
yeah yeah and I feel like that's one
thing that it doesn't really have a
place in The Hunger Games I guess but
you know that's one thing you don't get
a sense for as much yeah I'm there and I
feel like that's a tremendous asset to
him as an actor I don't know how much
Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg actually
directed of the series it might have
just been the pilot just the first 10
minutes first Evers before the first
don't be ready they seemed like the
perfect people to set up something like
this yeah because if there's one thing
you can count on with those guys is
genre comedy splicing and and like 80s
nostalgia references way beyond 80s
looks like they're going it's a time
travel [ __ ] that's the cool thing about
them that you spoofs but they also make
it cool oh you know and I feel like the
futuristic stuff that's what's gonna be
exciting about it is it'll be some funny
just time-travel references that we're
aware of or that we might have seen done
before but though they'll make it funny
they'll make fun of the day but they'll
also make it really cool and this is the
N is kind of scary at times yeah it's a
movie that doesn't skimp on what genre
it is and it doesn't get a free to be
imposing and be kind of uncomfortable
and stuff yeah yeah they're good at
playing up all of the important elements
of the genres that they're working at
and it looks like they're working in a
few different ones here it's funny cuz
like I was getting vibes of terminator
and back to the future and well anything
that deals with time travel there
they're dealing with their own mosh
there yeah one and a couple times they
called stuff out they were like you know
they did that the whole last starfighter
thing like you could tell this is
probably really self yeah and that's
something that to me and also that bro
geek culture references yeah there's
something huge with these guys you know
and that makes me you know excited and
curious to see what all they're gonna
bring in in terms of references yeah
that's always like a fun bingo card with
these guys I feel like I feel like in
the hands of most filmmakers this kind
of thing would be might just be goofy or
cheesy that's the main the main thing
about it love about this is it looks
actually really cool and exciting but
also hilarious same time yeah it looks
like they got a little production value
on decided for a man I'm excited for it
oh yeah before we wrap up this video
Nathan Wilton here's your shout out
buddy he's one of our Australian patrons
I'll do it I've been Nathan Wilton would
love it I feel like Nathan Wilton with
love he's a gamer he has like a VR said
he has a crazy computer setup he's all
about technology I feel like Nathan
Wilson could relate to this Josh
Hutcherson character yeah I feel like
this would be the kind of adventure
Nathan Wilson's life would would embark
upon you know yeah really the only
difference is Nathan Wilson gets laid a
lot more it seems like yeah doesn't seem
like way to song is making it happen
yeah Josh Hutcherson looks more like
relatable and nerdy and shy and
introverted Nathan Wilton he's sexy and
I believe we did a Google hangout he he
was getting laid while we were doing the
hangout yeah it was sort of like we were
talking to his sex tape and then of how
I felt he canceled the last one this was
actually true last one he was in bed
first time I heard that
hey the Milton my friend
gotta have another Google hangout going
buddy thank you for being a part of our
patreon you're one sexy nerd I don't
know what your sister looks like but if
she looks anything like you that does
nothing for me because you live in
Australia subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell - on
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram he is
a social media manager of reject nation
take care people